Most of the time, animated films are synonymous
with family entertainment, forced to defy
expectations of being “just for kids.”
But animated movies have proven to be every
bit as powerful as their live-action siblings,
with filmmakers using the platform to tell
compelling and heartfelt stories that speak
to entire generations. Here are Screen Rant’s
10 best animated films ever made.
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs
The first animated production by Walt Disney
Studios, Snow White had an impact on the industry
that few will ever rival. Combining vibrant
art with some standout musical selections,
the film showed audiences that a brand new
medium was on its way to theatres. But it
would have been all for nothing if not for
the memorable story. Viewers responded most
to the great collection of characters, which
are still heavily marketed nearly 80 years
after its release. Couple that with a narrative
that spoke to both young and old, and you’ve
got one of the most revolutionary movies ever
put to film.
The Lion King
Launching a new era for Disney Animation,TheLionKingwas
the comeback project the studio needed to
regain top form. Fuelled by an emotionally-driven
story on par with a Greek tragedy, it found
the right balance between high drama and comedic
hijinks. As one would expect, the animation
was beautifully realized, making the film
a technical achievement as well. Between the
great characters, memorable songs, and relatable
themes, it was an instant classic as soon
as it hit theatres.
The Nightmare Before Christmas
One of the more inventive movies that ever
graced the animated genre, this Tim Burton
production captured the imagination of viewers
of all ages. Blending music, comedy, and romance
against the holidays of both Christmas and
Halloween, this Nightmare shows a style and
ambition that few have ever tried to copy.
The movie’s characters are grotesque or
endearing enough to win over children, but
their personalities and deception can only
be grasped by their parents. The stop-motion
techniques on display were also considered
revolutionary, making the film a technical
spectacle as well as an emotional one.
Toy Story
Pixar is the premiere animation studio in
the world today, and their first film’s
success is a main reason why. Toy Story set
the template many of their future projects
would follow, as they crafted a thrilling
adventure that both kids and adults could
relate to. Youngsters appreciated the colourful
collection of toys, while their parents were
able to pick up on the themes of growing older
and being replaced by something new. Combining
heart, humour, and emotion, the movie’s
screenplay was even nominated for an Oscar
– showing Pixar had what it took to be a
major force in the industry.
The Iron Giant
Brad Bird has made the leap to live-action
blockbusters, but he got his start with this
WB animated feature. A variation of the “boy
and his dog” trope, The Iron Giant is a
story that a viewer of any age can enjoy.
Fuelled by an allegorical tale about politics
and military power, the film was much more
complex and well-performed than a children’s
movie ever needs to be. Wearing its heart
and affection on its sleeve, and dealing with
serious problems head on, it found a way to
balance the awe-inspiring magic of movies
with a story about the fear of the unknown.
The film’s star Hogarth may resemble the
children who loved it, but to us, The Iron
Giant was the first time that the rough, tough
Vin Diesel worked his way into our hearts
– using his voice alone.
Spirited Away
Studio Ghibli is one of the industry’s top
animation studios, and this Oscar-winning
feature shows nearly every reason why, from
art style to its overall message. Everything
from the film’s voice acting to its direction
were immediately praised by critics, who universally
demanded that Spirited Away was the kind of
whimsical fantasy that deserved to be seen
by all children. Walking the line between
eerie, terrifying, and downright fantastic,
the movie is one of the few that can be equally
enjoyed by all ages, and across every culture.
Not every animated film dares to dive into
deep social commentary to provide strong substance,
but we’re appreciative this one did.
Finding Nemo
Pixar had reached the top of their game in
the 2000s, and this tale of a fish in search
of his son is one of their landmark achievements.
The film possessed the kind of universal messages
that audiences have come to expect from the
studio, in this case focusing on parent-child
bonds, and how and when children must seek
out their own independence. The love between
Nemo and Marlin is one for the ages, and the
two only realizing it once they had been separated
by a vast ocean was the driving force of the
narrative. Like so many other Pixar films,
the supporting characters were top notch as
well, with the tank gang – and especially
Dory – finding a permanent place in our
hearts.
How to Train Your Dragon
DreamWorks may often be seen as standing in
the shadow of Pixar, but every so often, they
break through with a winner of their own.
With a beautiful visual style and a rich and
witty screenplay, How to Train Your Dragon
is a perfect example of a family film done
with heart and intelligence. The movie’s
aerial sequences and heartwarming teamwork
between the young Hiccup and the dragon Toothless
lent weight to the standard third-act battles,
and delivered a happy ending despite all involved
being scarred in the process. A touching tale
of friendship with sufficient dramatic heft
and insight to please everyone in attendance,
it’s easy to see why this became on of the
studio’s flagship franchises. Who wouldn’t
want their own pet dragon?
Despicable Me
The Minions stole the spotlight, but the loveable
yellow creatures are hardly the only things
that made Despicable Me a modern animated
classic. At the film’s core is an unlikely
protagonist in Gru, a super-villain obsessed
with ruling the world - until he comes across
three adorable little girls who become much,
much more than pawns in his evil game. Over
the course of the film, Gru and his surrogate
daughters become a caring family, raising
serious questions about the ways in which
every parent organizes their priorities. Thoughtful,
humorous, and enough emotion to sell viewers,
Despicable Me is a heroic accomplishment that
shows there’s good in all of us.
The LEGO Movie
Ridiculed upon its announcement, audiences
everywhere were eating plenty of crow when
the film released. Wildly imaginative and
extremely creative, LEGO was able to crack
the Pixar formula of having something for
everyone, with sharp humour and well-timed
pop culture references that gave it a cross-generational
appeal. Directors Phil Lord and Chris Miller
were in top form, using the film to offer
biting social commentary and powerful statements
on relationships, childhood, consumerism,
and pack mentality. Full of exciting action,
crazy characters, celebrity cameos, well-hidden
jokes and plenty of laughs, LEGO showed that
a toy movie could be done right. In the end,
Everything really was awesome.
Those are our picks for the best animated
films ever made. Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favourites? Sound off
in the comments below and be sure to subscribe
to our channel for more videos like this one!